how is season 11 different from season
10 season 11 is gonna be different
because I ain't going home so stay tuned
Miz Vangie and drag race are back for
the show's most star-studded season yet
you'll be saying oh my Eileen Cyrus in
the house are you freaking out because
I'm freaking out what was Miley like as
a judge oh I have to take my sunglasses
off for this question you know I am very
black powerful and you know she had a
little beef with Nicki Minaj what's good
I don't know about this [ __ ] right here
but after getting to know her and she
gets to tell us her story I found a new
love for her I expect the best of both
worlds I'm here for it I think she's
very fair and she seemed like she was
like fine dope I don't know she's a
human she was a judge how much more
vague could I guess she was really into
it you know what I mean it wasn't it
wasn't like she was faking her happiness
or excitement she was really excited to
be there and to interact with us you
know if it wasn't like to be here and
she was engaged
you just feel like someone you want to
get to know as a person and that's who a
started Miley Cyrus is a drag race
fanatic you know she she is inducted
into the house of Edwards with Alyssa so
she knows director would see she is very
much a drag queen just like us so it was
like homegirl
we got a 16 testin girl she is through
and through the most chill the most real
and the most authentic I think that any
of us could hope for and I think that
that was like I was a fan before but now
I'm like I like Ryder diet like I'm in
love with her I was upset I wasn't
invited to the wedding but I have to
like expert Miley
would you forgive me for judging you
kabbadi it she's your homegirl she's the
girl you shoot the would have a shot wit
Medina it's like yeah girl I kind of
like that jacket though she's very much
like a Michelle and RuPaul combined for
me like she she definitely gives you it
gives it to you straight but there's
love and compassion behind her like
Michelle shoot crazy you know she's
gonna read you down but no Miley is just
just a beautiful beautiful soul and I
had no idea she was very uplifting she
was a rude or [ __ ] or anything she was
such a really like nice cool chick gave
us a little pep talk you know made us
feel like really comfortable about the
first episode we're like oh my god we're
here in sanity but she kind of was like
just be breathin keep it movin Miley
breath right there I was in a very very
emotional place with his like girl and I
remember being like hey girl how do you
like you know I deal with all of this
how do you deal with all of this
pressure and she just looked an amazing
source of like love and light and
guidance for all of us and it was really
an honor to like see a face on the into
the runways and I you know grew up
watching watching and rocking out you it
was magical
like there's Hannah Montana right I was
like oh my god I'm literally saying fun
front of Miley sighs like what the hell
like is this real like everything was
just it was a lot to process to the
first day it was just so much going on I
eaten up like like loving her even
though she ain't great working that came
from black people honey all right I have
a deep love for her and a new found
respect for her artistry
[Music]
you
[Music]